is joining us today hi Ellen yeah she
brought me yet she brought me here kid I
love Ellen I did not bring any
televisions though I apologize but
you're you're out we're an egg hot
winter so you don't need to bring
anything you just show up and bless us
you've been you know sometimes we trade
favors in the business and Kelly has
been on my show yeah trailer talk talk
[Applause]
trailer talk it has a waist smaller
budget than Kelly Clarkson show we don't
have any mics we we don't have proper
seating for our guests
we only air it on IG TV but we do sing
songs together
I miss Terry Crews the other day in the
countdown to the voice I was so sad I
love him we sang anniversary by Tony
Tony Tony you know oh my gosh I love him
he's fantastic I love him okay but wait
I do have a question though because I
feel like y'all travel Oh every time I
see you at the oyster like we just got
back from Japan we just go back from
Russia or just come and I'm like geez
like how are Christina kids how are
y'all doing everybody's jet-lagged yes
we just got back from Thailand like I'm
telling you it's a different country
like even like it you know somebody's
like I went to Nebraska like something a
whole flight like a whole thing well I
have gigs a lot of times
yeah that's Thailand oh my gosh so
Chrissy's mother is from Thailand if you
guys want to follow her on Instagram
she's an Instagram e too
she's hilarious she's pepper tied to on
Instagram but she's originally from
Thailand and we went to visit Thailand
for the first time with the kids they've
never been there to see their
grandmother's homeland and so it was
cool we got to see some of the relatives
and we had a really good time yeah I
loved it
it's beautiful the food's amazing ate
some crazy things though
oh yeah I don't do that I try anything
I'll try anything had a quickie me no
okay I won't know was it covered in
chocolate
not eat it then it could have used some
seasoning actually it was alright it
wasn't it wasn't bad my stomach's still
fine
wait so Chrissy the thing I love about
our choice calls you out on online yes
she calls him how all the time like
makes fun of him hard all the time
nobody so it should she'd recently do
with the insta husband was well she made
a post about how no one ever takes
pictures of her on vacation and she
feels like woe is me no one no one gets
good angles of me and I felt like I was
being directly attacked and I feel like
I take really good pictures of her and
she post some of them and so I made a
point of pointing out first of all did
she ever take a bad picture cuz I don't
think she does but alright I make an
effort to you know give her good
lighting and you gave her good angles
and so I
I posted these afterwards and my hashtag
was good Instagram husband because I
wanted to prove because indeed wait
who's a friend of ours two great
basketball player he he said basically
when women get married now I think part
of what they're getting with getting a
husband is getting someone who take
Instagram photos of them for life
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because I feel like it's like I feel
like I don't have anything like prolific
or anything relevant to say like I it's
really hard so that's why you have a
talk show what I actually want to hear
this this answer because I don't
actually know this full answer but how
did you and Chrissy me because I know we
were on do this together and our dating
about how did y'all meet we met in 2006
and it's actually our anniversary week
yes
so we met on the day my second album
once again was released September 13th
of 2006 and I shot a music video that
day with her she was the lead woman in
the music video and the guy who shot the
video is a good friend of ours and he
knew both of us and he thought we might
hit it off and he was like showed me a
picture of her and was like do you mind
if I cast her in the video and he was
like I think you'll like her
and I think he did I think I liked her
and so we we've been dating since
September of 2006 and we got married in
September of 2013 so it's our dual
anniversary this week we're going to
Paris
[Applause]
as you may know John and I are both
coaches on the voice which which I have
one more bit spine Owens County she's
never beaten me premieres September 23rd
[Applause]
when Stefani there are other two judges
this season what's been your favorite
part of the show this season
I love how deep the talent is this year
I really feel like I feel like last
season which was my first season I think
there were clear favorites that were
like really like head and shoulders
above the rest but this year I feel like
the depth from like the top half of my
team to the bottom half is like it's
like this narrow it's like everybody's
really good and really close to each
other
it's no joke it's the best season I've
been on like as a like as a whole like
all the talent it's insane like so good
I'm having so much fun yargh win is
really great great chemistry with her I
had never worked with her before
me neither yeah yeah everybody spent I
like how she reels the cowboy in yes yes
it's the best season just to watch her
be flaky I want this one and then who
gives it I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this